est en direct de la préfecture de Nevers
Christophe gaillard bonsoir vous êtes en
position de vous maintenir donc pour le
deuxième tour ici à Nevers
oui bonsoir oui c'est ça puisque nous
dépassons donc les 10% dès le premier
tour dès le premier tour oui victoire
donc pour vous
oui c'est une grande victoire une belle
victoire c'était un pari risqué que nous
avions fait mon équipe et moi-même
puisque nous avions décidé de ne plus
nous exprimer dans la presse locale qui
nous avait
savonné la planche fait un certain
nombre de mauvais procès et puis nous
avions décidé donc de communiquer par
nos propres moyens et nous avons réussi
ce Paris aujourd'hui
action question
sur ce résultat il y a quand même
beaucoup de listes qui peuvent se
maintenir au deuxième tour à Nevers vous
votre objectif c'est quoi ça va être
siéger au conseil municipal c'est
essayer de discuter avec avec d'autres
listes sur Nevers on sait qu'il y a une
liste qui est à qui se dit apolitique et
qui arrive en deuxième position est-ce
que vous avez des des projets
non nous notre ligne politique est très
claire pas d'alliance pas d'union avec
d'autres parties ou avec d'autres forces
politiques donc nous resterons seuls au
deuxième tour nous nous maintiendrons et
puis nous représenterons les les noeuds
vers soi qui ont fait le plaisir de nous
accorder leur suffrage et puis je pense
que nous avons besoin de représenter ces
9 Versoix puisque nous serons les seuls
donc au deuxième tour à parler
immigration à parler insécurité et à
parler de l'Europe comme on le fait au
niveau national nous serons les seuls à
représenter donc les 9 Versoix à la
municipalité et puis plus tard je
l'espère dans le dans le département au
conseil général à la région et puis lors
de des législatives la représentation
nationale bien entendu